hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast and
I am just checking in on you okay no
bells no whistles on it this week I'm
just checking in on you so you know
everything's going hoping you have in a
nice week I'm having a lovely week been
doing a bunch of a bunch of what do you
call it their promotion for F it's a
family that comes out next Tuesday at
midnight on Netflix season to ten
episodes of the Murphy family on Netflix
please tune in if you enjoy it please
continue to watch all ten if you enjoy
all ten please tell your friends and
have them watch it so then we could do
what season three three three yeah yeah
yeah we'll see what happens I um it's
been such a whirlwind of prayeth what
the [ __ ] did I do yesterday or two
nights ago I was at something I wore a
sport coat I do know that I have
absolutely no recollection where I was
two nights ago last night we went over
to Netflix his new building they're
taking over the world the new building
and oh I know what I did I know what I
did there was four Emmy consideration
they added they had the thing there and
you sat there on a pan panel and it was
Judd Apatow
Chelsea Handler the woman who created
friends I can tell you right now if I
created friends I would never come out
of the house again I'd have so much
goddamn money I would just be sitting in
there with the biggest drum kit ever and
I'd have a [ __ ] helicopter I don't
know what I'd be it I'd be all [ __ ]
weird I'd be like growing my nail not
cutting my nails
you know I'd be coward [ __ ] Hughes it
was me and then the guy from the santa
clarita diet it was pretty cool you got
to sit there and every said tell us you
know what you're creating
show what is it that you do when you're
creating the show um there's any other
stuff in the show is it based on you is
it made up or is it something else that
we don't know all together and he
answered all the questions and you hope
you get out of it unscathed which I
think I did sorry so what's funny was I
actually wore a sport coat and then Mike
price co-creative efforts of family the
great Mike Price from The Simpsons who I
could not do afters for family without
him
he was dressed casual so last night when
we went to the new netflix building
they're taking over the world um I I
said I I'm not gonna I said any I go you
know what I'm just gonna wear a [ __ ]
button-down blah blah and as I pull in
Mike price has a jacket on I got you now
on the bum so we were laughing about
that everybody else had on a jacket so I
just look like the [ __ ] artist
showing up like hey Mia and I just like
roll out of bed man and yeah you know
when everyone feel and I did put it on
man but we sat through two episodes the
first two episodes it was a friendly
though you know everybody pretty much in
the crowd was on the show and they were
laughing having a good time so I hope
you guys enjoy it I was on Rich Eisen
yesterday I don't know if he can go to
some Rich Eisen net and watch it I had a
great time so thank you to him and then
I did Bill Simmons had a great time on
that one and I got coming up next week I
know I'm doing Craig Ferguson who's the
greatest fashion I've ever seen I'm
doing his and something else let me look
at my phone I should be I'm trying to
promote these things before I do it I
would probably be good right rather than
telling you after I did him I mean that
would make sense bill the whole thing
about promotions let people know
something's coming not that it came and
went oh I know I actually I have a gig
for the California Highway Patrol
boo-boo but I do
but a dead dead dead dead it did it oh
yeah I'm gonna be on my best behavior
you cannot know enough cops there's some
great life advice you have no idea when
you're gonna snap you just walk into a
bank you're gonna make a deposit you
just think hey what if I just pulled my
shirt up over my head and passed him a
note you know you have no idea went for
some stupid [ __ ] reason you do that
and then fortunately when the cop shows
up he's like get on a ground away that
bill dude what are you doing alright now
I'll take care of this everything's fine
there was no gun alright it takes you
outside what the [ __ ] you gotta get out
of here get out of here you son of a
[ __ ] you like that that right there is
called white privilege I don't know
who's not white who listens that you
know many times I've gone in and robbed
a bank and it's you know I've never been
successful but I've never gone to jail
for it
it's because I am a white male you know
and I might get in trouble for this I
might lose some of my privileges by
letting on Whitey's know that I've
actually on six maybe seven if you want
to get technical
first time it was I made a joke but on
set six and a half different occasions I
made an attempt to rob a bank I was
caught but knew the cop when they were
coming in five out of six of those
another time the guy was like oh you
look just like me hey let me go
those were all true stories then you can
add those to the to the non fake news in
your life
I flew a [ __ ] helicopter this morning
been getting back into it I'm up over
120 hours my auto rotations are looking
okay last week they were [ __ ]
horrific put the collective down [ __ ]
nose followed it and I didn't go after
it was like oh my god am I gonna die
getting good on the radio again I got
this great [ __ ] app if you want to
listen anybody else there is into
aviation of something I just you know
because you don't wanna sound like a
[ __ ] [ __ ] when you're making your
calls which you know I do on a regular
basis there's an app called live ATC net
it's really cool and you just click and
you can listen to whatever airport you
want
I was listening you know when my flights
taken off
you know I don't care about was it
magnetic deviation or whatever [ __ ] it
is from my cellphone I wasn't magnetic
something-or-other retardation I can't I
don't know all I know is I'm going back
and I'm going through all my ground
school again trying to remember all the
[ __ ] I'm reading about [ __ ] weather
and I'm having a great time get myself
back to where my skill level was right
before my lovely daughter was born and I
don't know I'm totally into it but the
only thing I don't like about those
Robinsons is that the mass bumping and
the Logie pushovers and some was telling
me today that they had a fully
articulated rotor system we didn't have
to [ __ ] deal with that for those of
you don't fly a mass bumping is
basically when the blades attack the
mast and break off the helicopter if
they don't get bent and then slam into
the cockpit and cut your [ __ ] legs
off are you right in half you know that
could happen so that happened on those
Bell helicopters I guess that they had
in Vietnam and you can't you know when
they would fly low to the ground that go
up to hill and you know because they
were trying to stay at the tree line so
they wouldn't get shot at they're way up
in the air and they would just fly and
they'd go up the hill and then when they
would dive down the backside that's the
thing when you push forward with the
stick like that you're not supposed to
do that in a semi articulated rotor
system what happens to the see if I can
remember basically what happens is the
main rotor is still spinning but it's no
longer producing lift with the
helicopter right you've sort of been
this low G thing so what happens is if
it goes counterclockwise your main rotor
your your rear tail rotor is going to be
on back behind you on the left and so
you're it's still going to be
compensating for the torque that the
main rotor is no longer producing so
it's going to push you over you're going
to roll over to the right and what's
[ __ ] up is as you roll over to the
right the way to get out of it is
counter-intuitive you would think that
you would move the stick left you don't
you smooth it slightly back after you go
aft to reload the main rotor to get back
underneath it so it's just [ __ ]
watching the ground coming up on the
right like I don't want to go
there you move the stick like you want
to do a backward somersault rather than
roll back up it's completely [ __ ] up
you got one chance to do it if you pull
back too fast I think he chopped your
tail off so there's that which is why I
don't fly if there's any sort of wind I
don't fly but you know there's a danger
with anything that you do if you're not
risking are you really living I have to
get on Instagram and I have to become
some sort of motivational comedian
that's what I want to do I want to start
giving you guys nauseating [ __ ] life
lessons you know as I'm leaving a gym or
a [ __ ] juice bar what is with all
these [ __ ] [ __ ] on on Instagram
acting like they're trying to inspire
you it's you're not you're trying to
show me what great shape you're in
hashtag doing this one for you guys the
[ __ ] out of here
Instagram [ __ ] male and female all
right so the Celtics they want a game
holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] so we have Game five
tonight which every Celtic fan knows
that we are basically eight quarters
away if we can survive the next eight
quarters we are eight no actually not
eight quarters the next eleven quarters
we are 11 quarters away from Kelly
Olynyk taking over this [ __ ] series
and getting us to the finals I know I
say it Thomas is out I know they got
[ __ ] LeBron Kevin Love they got all
these [ __ ] I understand okay do
you know what Boston has we got hot so
we always have never have explosive
speed we have a strict no explosive miss
with all our draft players if he's got a
quick first step and can dunk we're like
now past that guy on what can this guy
do look like he's going to trip over his
own feet and he's white give me that guy
you always happened then we got the like
the the bruising black dudes but we just
never have those above the rim guys we
just don't have explosive guys you know
Isaiah is but you know he's like five
foot eight so all I'm saying okay but
you know Crowder he's gonna get us a you
know something younger kids though
Browne Bradley those guys
I love how Bradley keeps trying to dunk
on the brunt it keeps missing the
[ __ ] rim though that would I like
that guy
so anyways I don't know what I'm talking
about all I know is the remaining
Celtics just all you got to do is get us
to the fourth quarter in game 7 all
right and then the gardens gonna come
alive Cali Cali Cali and he's going to
hit a [ __ ] zone and I don't know
what's going to happen he's going to be
so in the zone he's not even need a
headband anymore to keep his his locks
out of his face and he's just gonna I
don't know if he started draining threes
and that's going to be all she wrote for
the land ok anybody want to put money on
it I'll put money on it right now if we
can somehow survive the next 11 quarters
Kelly that was not a fluke everybody
thinks it's a fluke I'm telling you that
man has ice water in his veins Arctic
[ __ ] polar bears swimming around in
his [ __ ] veins microscopic lungs I'm
telling you the thing is he's just bored
he doesn't give a [ __ ] about game 5 one
through four or even game six or even
the first [ __ ] half actually no he
had a good game game son we just have to
get to Game seven
and the man that I've always been
confused as to why he was on the team I
once again got hit with a cold bucket of
reality of Bill you're just a stand-up
comic you don't know [ __ ] about sports
let Danny Ainge make the calls and if
Danny Ainge says Kelly Olynyk is the
[ __ ] man that I I'm standing down you
a Cleveland I know you [ __ ] nervous
you what you are so scared that we are
somehow going to win Game five in game
six without Isiah Thomas well Kelly
Olynyk gets dunked on and people go
right around but you [ __ ] wait man we
get to Game seven it's over that man
shows up to play
all right I'm an idiot anyways okay
Kaleigh um let's uh let's move on the
the Predators holy [ __ ] hey anybody in
montreal the montreal canadiens did you
notice that the guy that you traded for
cuz he was too flashy you know didn't
like his personality pique subhan it was
really your front office on this one but
i'm going to blame the fan base yet
another former canadian leading a team
to the finals leading a team to the
final of was my front door by the way if
you wonder what that beep was I didn't
leave the refrigerator open I'm so
hoping that the Predators win the Cup
because the Bruins will never catch the
Montreal Canadiens and the amount of
Stanley Cups they have so all I can do
is tease them about the guys that they
got rid of and that then went on to win
cups elsewhere is it petit oh I think
it's I think it's very petit who do you
like tonight Game seven
Game seven penguins penguins where's the
[ __ ] Ottawa Senators where is that
game it was it in Ottawa if you're in
Pittsburgh you want to go to the game
you can probably just walk up to the
gate and buy a ticket God knows it's a
transient city you know it's a capital
people don't give a [ __ ] they're from
other places they're Calgary fans that
live there Edmonton Blue Jackets they
don't give a [ __ ] they're not going to
the goddamn game what do you guys think
I actually for some fucked-up reason I
think I think Ottawa is going to win
only because I don't know the Penguins
have had a little bit of goaltender
issue there that's the only reason
that's what I'm guessing the ten seconds
that I paid attention why do I talk
about sports right now too [ __ ] busy
running around doing podcast you know
what I was so busy last week I forgot to
read the the question so let me read
this here's another person giving me
[ __ ] about bills fake news Delta rant
Billy fake [ __ ] news I was listening
to your podcast from last Monday as I
was sitting on a Delta flight heading to
Los Angeles from Austin Texas was that
partner to the [ __ ] story and one of
your readers brought up the Delta
Airlines incident where a dad was
threatened to get kicked off and jailed
if he didn't stop complaining and fall
in line as I was listening to your
useless [ __ ] rant still a huge fan I
noticed how uninformed both you
your reader were on this situation all
right time out here first of all if you
guys are going to come at me with
uninformed and fake news are you new to
the podcast
I don't read just commented on four
[ __ ] series I've probably watched
three minutes and my job is to make you
laugh it's not to get facts what the
[ __ ] you think you listening to here sir
I could have easily googled that and
figured out what I was talking about
don't come at me like you're some sort
of Rhodes Scholar
like I'm impressed that you're going
from Los Angeles to Austin Texas are you
going to keep it weird man when you get
to Austin Texas Austin Texas is one of
the most overrated overpopulated [ __ ]
cities in this goddamn country you know
why cuz LA [ __ ] like you keep moving
there
well actually if you did your research
you'd realize that I'm not from LA nor
am i from Austin he lets me tell you
somebody I don't give a [ __ ] where
you're from the mere fact that you're
dumb enough to try to get [ __ ]
accurate information from this podcast
and you think that I'm uninformed I used
to do a radio show called uninformed
which with better call Saul's star
breakout star Joe DeRosa the teen idol
sensation sensation from the now-defunct
Opie and Anthony program that's what
really broke up Opie Anthony and Jimmy
it was the sheer star power of Joe
DeRosa coming in once every 16 weeks
they just all had to go their separate
ways because when they came back into
the studio when they looked at one
another all they could be reminded of
was was the force of Joe de Rosas Talent
all right you want to look that one up
they're going when you flight from LA to
Austin he said as I was listening in
blah blah
um okay I know it's okay first the seat
that the dad was bitching about being
sold to another passenger was actually
his 18-year old son seat all right now
where did you get this at Delta comm
because they're not I don't trust these
guys either I don't trust you either how
do I know you're not [ __ ] Eddie Delta
son of Ulysses Delta who [ __ ] started
the airline who we put on an earlier
flight by buying a separate ticket
instead of notifying Delta that he was
changing his son flight to an earlier
flight doing this he thought he could
magically have an open seat to him for
his toddler who was under too but that
wasn't the case Jesus this guy's
spreading the semen out huh
he's got a 18 year old in the toddler
there you go buddy keep banging away you
see when you decide to put your son
don't [ __ ] go you see like you're
[ __ ] talking down to me you dumb [ __ ]
all you did was research it my job sir
is to make people laugh that's it my job
is not the [ __ ] pump I don't have
[ __ ] time to figure [ __ ] out what am
I still in school I got in this business
to not have a job I'm like I sit here
and research your guy's [ __ ] emails I
don't care what you write to me unless
it sounds totally ridiculous I'm gonna
treat him as long I've also flown a lot
and I've noticed that they don't give a
[ __ ] about you
I mean one time I was on a flight and
they had the intercom on so goddamn loud
you needed like earplugs and I said to
the stewardess I go is there any way you
can turn that down a little bit and she
just goes now I'm sorry sir there's
nothing we can do about it it's like
you're telling me that they installed an
intercom system without a volume knob
and it was at full blast that's what
you're telling me sir why are you being
difficult I'm not being difficult all
right with you [ __ ] crooked toes all
right you see when you decide to put
your son on an earlier flight by buying
another ticket while not telling Delta
they assume that the the 18 year old son
did not make it on his original flight
because he didn't check in and they
weren't notified that the dad bought a
completely separate ticket so they gave
the seat away to a standby passenger per
standard protocol also FAA
this allows a child under two to sit in
a standard seat without the proper child
seat and harness so there's another
thing that dad got wrong you can't have
a child with a different name sit in a
seat that he sold your 18 year old son
all right fair enough
imagine all the the issues this would
cause cause if we what if we allowed for
anyone to use his any ticket that was
issued in someone else's name his
mistake was that he didn't check in and
notify Delta and should have paid the
change fee to send his son on an earlier
flight with the same ticket and then buy
another ticket first toddler if he had
the proper safety harness for the
toddler tickets are not transferable to
another passenger I'm not defending the
flight attendant who I thought said some
things that were inappropriate by
threatening jail etc that's really what
I was commenting on buddy all right that
they're sitting there acting like he did
something in the Pentagon
however the dad was completely wrong to
think he can somehow put his oldest son
on an earlier flight home and then use
his original ticket well this guy he's
got an 18 year old the two year he's too
busy [ __ ] without a condom to
research all of this how about having a
little empathy for him sir on your Los
Angeles to Austin flight [ __ ] jackass
what is the oldest son's which is he
okay
what is okay however the dad was
completely wrong to think he could
somehow put his oldest son on an earlier
flight home and then use his original
ticket which is in his oldest son's name
how many times you're gonna say the same
thing on the two-year-old Tata so he and
she can he or she can sit in that seat
of Delta Neil wha just wanted to clear
up your fake news rent you misinformed
continent good everything's fake news is
it it wasn't fake news sir it was just
me trying to make you [ __ ] laugh okay
that's all it was okay I'm glad you
researched and cleared all of that up at
the end of the day at the end of the day
I'm just here to make you laugh okay so
please people for the love of God all
right
and stop acting like you know I can't do
what you just did okay girl stabs
boyfriend and avoid jail time because it
was damaged her career now what am I
supposed to do here sir am I really
supposed to [ __ ] sit here and
research this as if someone's going to
go to jail with the jokes that I do or
I just take it at loss so I can get on
with my [ __ ] life here's the deal
why don't you got why don't you be the
[ __ ] the fact police all right I'll
do the rant that next week you can
correct me
that was my uninformed show I did with
Joe DeRosa we just pick a topic we'd go
off on it we'd be completely wrong and
then we'd bring an expert in that was
literally the show people would learn
things and there was laughs we had all
right girl stabs boyfriend and avoids
jail time because it would damage her
career hey there Billy beets I'm sure a
million people tweeted an email you this
article actually no they did maybe they
did I don't know this girl's stabbed her
boyfriend but the judge agreed that any
sentencing would damage her future
career in medicine Jesus Christ go [ __ ]
yourself all right let me read this here
go to the page oh here we go click here
oh this this is UK news god knows has
probably happened in America I find the
UK people love to [ __ ] did you see
this that happened in your country you
guys are all fat and stupid all right
here we go
Wow Jesus ah well I see what happened
she's got this little angel smirk on her
face aspiring surgeon levena Woodward
admits attack but Judge defer sentencing
because of her extraordinary talent what
he blew her back in his [ __ ] chambers
an Oxford University student who's
whiter than my [ __ ] legs stabbed a
boyfriend with a bread knife okay it's a
bread knife may not go to jail because
it could damage her prospects of a
medical career a court has heard well
what's her training and maybe she could
have stabbed them and sewed him up real
quick
aspiring Hat surgeon Lavinia wouldwould
24 punched and stabbed a boyfriend
during an alcohol drug field row at
Christ Church College this is em on the
Guardian calm as is credible she so
she's on drugs and she's drunk and she
punched and stabbed her boyfriend she
admitted unlawfully wounding the
Cambridge University student who she met
on the dating app tinder
all right well not to blame the victim
but what did he do you can do that with
men what did he do judge Ian they're
always named Ian over there
Ian Pringle Nigel are in QC sitting at
Oxford Crown Court oh this is like the
school court is that what it is
did she go to trial at the [ __ ]
school that's taking her money
I know said he would take an exceptional
course into first sentence for four
months hinting that woodward would not
be jailed because of her talent it seems
to me that this was a one-off this was a
one-off drunk drugged up stabbing is
that what goes on in England if you go
to Oxford they give you one free pass as
long as it's a bread night for not a
steak knife a complete one-off to
prevent this extraordinary extraordinary
able young talent young lady lady from
not following her long-held desired to
enter the profession she wishes to would
be a sentence would be uh which would be
a sentence which would be too severe
there's some [ __ ] judge speak to
enter the profession she wishes to would
be a sentence which would be too severe
he said that sounded fake that sounds
like somebody trying to sound like a
judge well you did we'll never I know
leave you but it was pretty awful pretty
awful that's an understatement and
normally it would attract a custodial
sentence she's going to be a janitor
whether it's immediate or suspended he
said Woodward who lives in Milan Italy
with the mother stabbed her
then-boyfriend in the leg after punching
him in the face it was below the way so
that's a misdemeanor right she then
hurled a laptop glass and Jam jarred him
during the attack on the 30th of
September last year the court heard she
was in court to hear the judges comments
the court was told that christchurch
would allow her to return in october
because she is that bright and has had
articles published in medical journals
do you realize that if this is true how
[ __ ] up this is
that then they have the trap car that
they drive down to impoverished areas
and they leave it on with the keys in it
and the door open why don't you [ __ ]
help somebody out down there you got to
be white as a ghost going to [ __ ]
Oxford they know they're gonna make a
bunch of money off you're given a
prescription drug some day Wow alright
anyways Woodward will be sentenced on
the 25th of September she was given a
restraining order and told to stay
drug-free and not to reoffended on't
mind could you stay away from the person
you stabbed and lay off the [ __ ]
pills or whatever the hell he said she
had taken a spokeman for Christ's sure
said I'm afraid that Christchurch does
not comment on the circumstances of
individual students I'm a little
confused if that was a I would think
that that would make it to real Court
not just she's a little thing too
[ __ ] lunatic abut she's an animal in
the wreck huh um yeah I mean that's par
for the course I mean women do not pay
the same [ __ ] price you know white
guys get away with [ __ ] that black guys
dead that's all [ __ ] there's all
different before you do the crime you
really should just do the math be like
what am i oh what's up sweetheart she's
coming in India I can't be funny without
cursing you can't bring my lovely
daughter is that my daughter in there my
um am i watching her now is that what's
going on oh you're coming to hang out oh
you want to be on the podcast hey listen
to this [ __ ] some woman punched stabbed
in through a laptop through a window and
a drug and alcohol fuel rage and they
gave her a suspended sentence because of
her extraordinary talent in the medal or
pretend you could damage her career in
the future
no she stabbed her boyfriend in the leg
Oh get over here with a bread knife it
was a bread knife you know what the [ __ ]
go around stabbing people
right knife neo Rene hill you know you
want to make a bumper sticker you know
what that's good you can't go around
stabbing people that's right you can't
go around stabbing people even if it's
with a butter knife so what is it they
let her off why I'll show you what it is
that's what it is Neal she is white yeah
Oxford yeah okay she could damage her
career oh go [ __ ] yourself with her a
little four other little little blondie
white girl and a moto jacket mm-hmm
mm-hmm that says it is sit in this world
yeah exactly okay when she actually
killed somebody next time we'll see you
can't kill some of the butter knife show
use I shall use this [ __ ] steak knife
next she's crazy is a butter knife a
gateway to a steak knife I believe so I
believe if you're willing to pick up a
butter knife you're willing to pick up
just about anything you can clewd your
case yeah can I can I hear your closing
arguments for this white lady if you
were talking to the jury all right
you're in England see wearing a powdered
wig so it's even more creepily white for
you go ahead I have I have to wear the I
think everybody has to wear one over
there they're begging to dress up over
there I'm a king I'm a queen who I'm the
Duchess okay ladies and gentlemen of the
jury I know that what's-her-name Lavinia
I know Lavinia Lavinia Woodward looks
innocent but you're staring into the
eyes of a psychopathic would-be killer
that's all I got
ah man I thought you're gonna trash her
nice wispy waify little white [ __ ] yeah
break if I tried to hand her a nail file
all right from an airline mechanic to
complete with to compete with cheapo
airlines like southwest of JetBlue the
majors need to over sell seats in the
case a passenger misses their flight
when passengers miss flights they
essentially buy two seats for one the
one they missed and the one the airline
rebooked them on they do this to
maximize revenue per flight I'm against
what United did because they could have
paid someone 1 million for this seat and
still not lost as much as they
unfortunately entitled people want to
pay for an uber and sit first-class it's
hard to balance enough profit to operate
in a 3:21 cross country keep prices low
and still try to run the airline like it
did in the 70s flying isn't as
prestigious as it used to be and
everyone is looking for a way to save a
buck love the show and go [ __ ] yourself
alright so evidently passengers are also
to blame well let me ask well what was
going on in the 70s that isn't going on
now is there way more people flying did
you guys go after bottom feeders so you
have more airplanes so you have more
overhead I don't understand why it was
so procedure prestigious back in the Ron
Burgundy days and they treated you way
better and now they just jam everybody
you know in the back of the plane and
try to put the seats closer together so
they can get more rows did you say Ron
Burgundy yeah that's not a real person
mm-hmm no but that the error was like in
the 70s okay the Ron Burgundy 70s what's
the matter with that it's the matter
with that man I would say I want it why
is that this is really interesting to
hear from people to actually work in the
field like what happened um what
happened did the price of fuel go up so
I don't get it why when they just raised
ticket prices because on the average
person couldn't afford it well good then
get him the eff out of there right wait
what sorry I don't know why I came in
here I'm really kind of checked out all
right well you get we got you've been
dealing with the kid all day who puked
on me right before I did this
she didn't puke it was spit up and it's
just a little bit you act like you're
witnessing someone getting executed in
front of you every time she spits up
you're like Jesus crying oh my god like
all of humanity like didn't I was
sitting there she was smiling and out of
nowhere she went that it just [ __ ]
all came out it's all warm it's like
somebody poured clam chowder on me and I
was laying down so went on my shirt my
belt my pants and it's just like yeah I
think I the normal reaction to somebody
puking on you no matter how
cute they are how cute of you
all right I hope that wasn't a bunch of
silence there maybe it was maybe it
wasn't I don't know um I see someone
wrote you something about an article
that I read oh my family's slaves
article yeah yeah that was an intense
article I wonder what does this person
say can you read the question yeah
that's what I was going to do could you
not sit on the recorder again alright my
family
slaves article hey Bilbo Baggins
longtime listener first-time a male uh
uh I read an article written by Alex
Tizen he's dead now okay that shocked me
but didn't really necessarily surprise
me and I love your cultural your
cultural perspective on it oh my god
this is so [ __ ] long in this article
this guy's talks about his family owned
a slave for 50 years
even after immigrating to America they
smuggled her with them in all that they
treated her like [ __ ] never paying her
forcing her to sleep on top of laundry I
imagine it's the dirty laundry why would
you want to have somebody and constantly
beating her for the tiniest of errors
only when the writer grew up with an
American identity that he realized with
what they were doing to the poor woman
wasn't right did he and his sibling
confront their parents over this Hey
ladies
sleeps on our clothes according my
teacher that's not right as a guy of
Chinese descent raised in the Americas
raised in America I've witnessed poor
people like this firsthand growing up
visiting family back in Hong Kong I'd
see my cousin there Millennials by the
way being tended to by a young Filipino
girl no older than her 20s I never
thought much of this back then looking
back it seems pretty [ __ ] up I asked
my mother about these kinds of people
and she simply said that's just the way
things are these girls are poor they
need to support their family and that's
the only kind of shitty employment that
they can get once my grandfather took me
past City Hall in Hong Kong on a Sunday
and I saw hundreds of young Filipino
girls just sitting on the ground doing
absolutely nothing I asked him what was
that all about he said
that Sunday was the day off and they had
nothing better to do than loiter they
sent all their money back home to their
families so it's not like they could
shop or go to a restaurant or anything
they ate and slept with their employers
I never seen my grandfather turn his
nose up at a group of people like that
but ever before
my grandfather whose parents were
murdered by the Japanese during World
War two
Wow yeah I've read about that [ __ ] The
Rape of Nanking every that [ __ ] they
[ __ ] Japanese went off and had to
walk to the orphanage after finding out
Jesus Christ I've had an easy life one
of the kindest most empathetic old farts
I know loved randomly hugging white
people he called them hellos because
that's what they'd say to him one of
these people out here's the article I'm
just curious what someone like you
raised with purely western-centric
ideologies would say about something
like this that well I mean this country
was kind of built on that yeah so yeah I
can't really step away - well we don't
do it anymore
yeah but uh yeah obviously I think it's
it's a risk I mean not now but you
should read the article it's pretty
powerful that whole thing because this
woman was given to his mother by her
father and they're Filipino and that's
just yeah they were just like here this
person is gonna take care of you so she
kept this woman throughout her life and
it became her children's care keeper
yeah cuz she didn't want to do any
[ __ ] work and then she moved to
America and be like oh my god I got to
take these kids out for a Sunday no no
that's again that's just like the
culture like this person is your nanny
and now like you inherit them or
something like that so it wasn't even as
if she had it's just part of their
tradition I after you know like all of
that this guy grew up and then he
realized that this woman wasn't getting
paid and all this other stuff and he
didn't realize until it dawned on him
like she is a slave and so he tried to
make things better for her in her later
life after his parents died and all this
kind of stuff back rub
ya know but by that time she you know
didn't know any other life so she didn't
really she wasn't like yeah I've been
waiting to go shopping at the mall like
this whole time this is so [ __ ] sad
that's like when it's very
Dubai Dubai they tell almost people in
Easter there that hey man come on here
and help us build all these beautiful
buildings you make all this money you'll
get out of poverty then they get them
there and then they confiscate their
passports and it's just slave labor that
builds those [ __ ] places and then
they like the number one the only way to
get out of is they like commit suicide
right it's [ __ ] brutal then you watch
your shows and the big balloon tinted
[ __ ] go over there to buy a [ __ ]
bag not a fan not a fan of Dubai not a
fan of Dubai why can't they be sinless
like the United States of America no
that's all horribly depressing and I
don't know what to tell you about that
as far as like I don't know how you do
that to somebody there you go and there
goes the comedy right out the window I
wonder why he i'm just curious of why
this person asked like i'm curious with
someone like you raised with purely
western-centric ideologies would say
about something like this again it's
like are you forgetting that this is
America that was built yeah but I didn't
grow up with that so what he wants to do
is get an outside perspective it's
actually an intelligent thing you mean
like hey I'm not from here I grew up
here but you know I also have
connections you know back there so what
do you think about this blah blah blah
you know what I think I think it's
terrible I'm gonna go on a limb and say
that that's [ __ ] terrible I have so
much more [ __ ] to read yeah you have to
get out of here cuz you're just gonna
you're gonna prolong it alright sorry
alright real quickly let me let me read
this cool cars hey Billy Bruin balls I'm
a huge fan all you ran and a excited
that you've become an f1 and MotoGP fan
I followed both of your these incredible
sports since the mid 80s if you haven't
already seen the documentary Sena or
Cena John Santa isn't I saw it actually
did watch I don't have props as NATO you
should it does a fantastic job of
explaining the myth around the great
Formula One driver in his intense
rivalry with McLaren teammate Alain
Prost I know you're always looking for
cool website here's a link to a really
cool Auto Auction website and it's a
bring a trailer calm I'll check that out
alright here we go
he has some [ __ ] advertisement before
we play a little music
then play a Greatest Hits thing alright
five phowa
mention the importance of feeling good
in your clothes oh my god when I walk
around in jeans I want my [ __ ] legs
to feel great
looking good doesn't need to cost a
fortune five for club is revolutionizing
the way men shop not the ladies the way
the men do it at 5-4 club they found a
way to make men under five foot four
look stylish to tall women
no at 5-4 club they found a way to make
great-looking clothes affordable for
everyone else no Jesus is this person
servant going to make them sleeping on
top of the clothes before they saw them
together five four club also understands
that your time is extremely valuable
why wasted at the mall or wandering
around in the stores dude I swear to god
strip malls and malls do you think in
the future Nia do you think they're
going to exist anymore of more and more
companies like this there's going to be
no post office you won't go to the
[ __ ] mall everything's going to be a
luxury high-rise right with indentured
servants milling around out front during
a Sunday I don't know each month they
send you a curated box of two to three
items that are hand-picked to match the
current season in your style five for
club partners with cutting-edge
designers and brands so you'll get the
same quality as top designer clothes for
way less they've been helping men with
fashion for over 15 years and shipped
over 100,000 men every month Chris Paul
and Mike Wahlberg use five for club and
five for is featured in GQ vice and
InStyle among other publications Nia
little look over they didn't believe
them absolutely well I'm on the way to
my Oscars you know someday I'm going to
call the five four club they know what
they're doing so if you don't that's
okay five four club will help you build
your wardrobe one month at a time Oh
bono put me on DS me on DS everyone
needs a slave but who do me undies me
undies work until they're in the grave
your balls feel nice and soft because
they polished him with the underwear
they may
that's [ __ ] evil but I'm white it's
part of my DNA I'm really sorry
all right me undies hey bill what do you
think about life long slavery and
somebody's dreams being crushed and so
crushed that they don't even have any
dreams and they don't want to do on a
Sunday I'd love to hear your
Massachusetts Western take on that
disgust all right pride starts on the
inside so celebrate yourself with me
undies me undies makes the ultimate
feel-good undies with free shipping
right to your door satisfaction
guaranteed designed in LA every pair of
me undies is made with micro motile
modal of fabric three times softer than
cotton they're soft stretchy undies come
in an ever-changing array of colors and
patterns no matter what your style
they've got something for you
that's because me undies believes and
people feeling good and it all starts
around your balls and being themselves
which is why me undies is putting their
money where their mouth is where their
underwear is and where your balls dangle
during Pride Month for every special
pair edition what for every pair of
special edition celebrate undies what
celebrate undies year you buy during
private poor [ __ ] bastards every
month they got to figure out a way to
make these things exciting me undies
will donate $1 to the Los Angeles LGBT
Center what is that long long Gary
Bateman technologies lesbian gay
bisexual and trans
is continental sexuals people who trance
who transfer whether they said trans
trans Lao transition on a flight across
the country what is their underwear look
like now wait a minute do they have
special underwear huh nasty Pig
underwear no you know what it is it's
like if you have a dick and then
eventually you're not going to have a
dick they offer the new slowly closing
front pee hole right underwear can they
do that slowly closes up they call it
the Bruce Jetta
and if the gold-medal underwear
decathalon underwear as and as if you
need another reason she liked it and if
you need another reason to try me undies
they're offering 20% off your first pair
and a satisfaction guarantee that you'll
love them or your money back just visit
our URL me undies dot-com / / head to me
undies comm and pick up a special pair
of edition celebrate undies I just can't
get through that sentence a special
edition celebrate undies celebrate is
like capitalized I mean it's it's
missing a word there's no comma so don't
go up like you know what's going on
you'll not only get a discount on some
awesome undies you'll be donating to an
amazing cause check out my undies comm
slash bird today you know what I
realized when they remove a dick
somebody has to take that put it in a
bag and like walk down a hall with it
and put it in like a hazmat thing like
where does that go where do you where
where do all the cutoff dicks go long
time passing you know that song where do
all the that was a Kingston trail long
long time
oh where did bruised his penis go that's
an iconic penis that should have gone to
the Smithsonian Institute that thing was
flopping left and right as he [ __ ]
threw javelins and all that stuff simply
safe everybody did you just have a body
part removed and you want to put it
somewhere safe
get a simply safe protecting your home
and family is easy with simply safe home
security simply safe enters sensors
motion sensors and glass break sensors
make your home a burglars worst
nightmare or biggest challenge if you're
going to keep talking [ __ ] can you
install you can install the system in
under an hour simply says-- comes
pre-programmed to work out of the box
just plug in the base station and I'll
talk you through the whole process
seriously even someone who isn't the
slightest bit handy can install it that
really means if you're a dumb [ __ ] like
me you can do it the entire system is
wireless so there's no need to drill
holes in your walls or do any other
permanent damage and once you're all set
up simply safe makes it is just as easy
to stay protected month to month was
simply safe there's no long-term
contracts no hidden fees it's just
$14.99 a month for 24/7 professional
monitoring and emergency dispatch
service that's three times less than
what the other guys charge go to simply
safe / calm si m p li SI fe there's no y
simply simply safe calm and get ten
percent off your home security system
that's simple I save calm for ten
percent off simply safe calm si MP Li
Sierra India Mike Papa Lima India
legalzoom.com Jesus Christ one more in
order to successfully run your business
attention to detail is so critical one
contract one contract slip-up and you
are [ __ ]
now once contract slip-up or legal
misunderstanding can really set you back
fortunately there's LegalZoom you may
already know that over
a million Americans have used LegalZoom
to start your business start businesses
but LegalZoom service go well beyond
business formation I'm sorry honey I
know it's hard to listen to me read out
loud
they built a nationwide network of
independent attorneys who can provide
legal answers to the day-to-day
questions you have about your business
because let's face it
things like trademarks employment laws
and lease agreements can get pretty
complicated so don't waste your time
your valuable time trying to wrap your
head around all of the fine print use
Legal Zoom for that so you can focus on
growing your business instead you'll get
the legal help you need without being
billed by the hour since LegalZoom isn't
a law firm go to legalzoom.com today and
be sure to enter the code birbee URR in
the referral box for special savings
only at legalzoom.com all right that is
the podcast for this month and I get
enough for this for this Thursday I'm
all over the map here thank you for
everybody writing in and I like
everybody writing in from aviation
defending the aviation land defending
your side of it that's good fair and
balanced uninformed [ __ ] is what's what
I'm all about
all right that's the podcast have a
great weekend and I can't say the c-word
I've said every other damn word here
from adult my daughter is that my
daughter in there
um hey I can't hey sweetie give me a
smile oh yeah it is
do you know only Nia can make her laugh
I'm bombing with my own daughter
it's devastating this is what I do for a
living all right enjoy the song and
enjoy greatest hits from a podcast gone
in a Thursday from a long time ago I'll
see you on Monday let's read some of the
other questions here for this week oh we
got an update I love when there's an
update remember last week the the granny
[ __ ] wanna remember that story all
right here we got an update hey there
old Billy [ __ ] water I got an update
for you on this one the story has good
news and bad news all right so lash last
week for those of you who didn't listen
I'll give you a little recap there was
some kid
uh you know he was he's basically he's
engaged he's getting married in six
weeks so he's over his fiance's house as
his future in-laws house her [ __ ]
parents that's all I'm trying to say
right so they're playing some card game
and evidently they're down to the final
hand and he has uh the cards called
granny water I don't know what the game
is or whatever some people sent me
pictures of the card the game does exist
but it's a really high point card or
whatever and he was laying down
welcome Yannick sorry he was laying down
his card last basically when he laid it
down he was going to do the old [ __ ]
right there fret I won the game
and he had the granny water card and I
guess in the end of the game is probably
you get it you hold on to it you played
at a crucial point
so everybody's sitting there as
everybody's laying the cards down
waiting to see who's gonna [ __ ] lay
it down so this kid [ __ ] finally his
turn he lays it down to be like you know
like hit in the last second three I just
won and because he listens to the
podcast instead of saying I got the
granny water card he goes he goes look
he goes it's all [ __ ] great now he
goes it's granny [ __ ] water and just
screamed it to his in-laws okay who
never heard this guy curse before and do
not listen to this podcast so they just
stared at him like Oh what what was that
what is my daughter marrying like he
just completely screwed the whole
[ __ ] thing up so he's asking me for
advice should he bring it up should he
not bring it up alright now you guys are
caught up here you go
he says the story has good news and bad
news the good news is my fiance's
parents were super cool about the whole
things I bit the bullet and waited until
we went over for game night again last
night
I apologized of course and they said
they initially just thought why were you
like this [ __ ] they initially thought it
was really odd for me to yell like that
without knowing without them knowing the
context but once it was explained my
fiancee texted them about it it was no
big deal
it was a huge relief we played the game
and and every time someone played that
card they did the whole granny water
thing - the [ __ ] in the middle okay
cool
he goes so my embarrassment will be
immortalized the bad news is that I
mentioned that you read the letter on
the podcast oh no you know what you're
one of those guys dude you just like you
just like step in and [ __ ] he goes
naturally they wanted to listen to it I
thought it wasn't a big deal because
they lived through the story and your
commentary was hilarious I warned them
about the explicit nature of your
podcast and that there were plenty of
[ __ ] throughout the fact that he did
the granny water thing before it was
even brought up was perfect everyone
thought the story was hilarious that is
until the PS if you recall I may or may
have not called Hillary Clinton a [ __ ]
oh Jesus that's right you did he goes
yeah I know I'm a dumbass bill my fiance
just turned to me and said did you write
that he said my fiance turned to me and
said did you write that with that look
on her face I knew I was [ __ ]
so freckles I did the only thing I could
I said oh sorry about that I didn't
write it
bills email screener guy did Andrew did
he picks the emails each week then
writes the little opening line pun and
then sometimes throws in a PS to make
them more entertaining well now why
would you write this because if they
listen to this you're [ __ ] you don't
do it I have no sympathy for you so here
we go he goes they bought it so we just
listened to the rest and we're laughing
again by the end so I threw Andrew under
the bus on that one I'm going to repeat
my only good move from the last story
and just shut the [ __ ] up about it
forever in the end all is well thanks
for reading it on the podcast it seemed
to help smooth it over no worries just
tell him not to listen to this one he
goes by the way um I just bought tickets
to your show and I'm not going to say
where the show is in case anybody's
figuring out of the [ __ ] this is
it's the week after my wedding and my
fiancee / wife by that point is coming -
I'd love to meet you in person Thanks
and go [ __ ] yourself uh all right will
you I'll be hanging out after in Iowa
just scream up I just said where it was
oh well you [ __ ]
granny water scream it out now [ __ ]
say hello to you
alright now everybody's going to do that
there hey what's up this is Bill burr
for some reason the podcast that I did
on Memorial Day I don't know it hasn't
been able to upload so now what I've
done is I've turned it into two parts
because I think it's been I think it was
too long so here is part one of the 54
minute Memorial Day Monday morning
podcast at the end of this one you'll
listen to part two huh yeah hey what's
going on it's Bill burr and it is the
Monday morning podcast for Monday May
25th 2009 happy Memorial Day to one and
all now you like that is that what are
the most happiest Kris Kringle ways I've
ever started a [ __ ] podcast yeah
happy Memorial Day and thank you to all
the all the troops out there who are
serving who have ever served and yeah
get yourself a burger today or whatever
the [ __ ] he's supposed to do in this
holiday what are you supposed to do he's
supposed to go to a parade is now what
you're supposed to do you know I'm not
going to a parade I I'm not big on
parades I don't like them I find them
boring once I've seen the first band I
get it alright
you're all basically playing the same
song it all sounds like the same song
and I hate when a big [ __ ] college
band starts playing top 40 hits like
it's gonna sound good you know like oh
that's the way Beyonce should have done
that song she should have had 58 guys on
a tuba and 26 guys on trumpets all
playing that [ __ ] guy if you like a
dad you better put a rig on it with the
[ __ ] trouble
[Music]
you know 28 [ __ ] guys doing that [ __ ]
and then you're all [ __ ] walking with
the same feet hey we're all taking a
left at the same time ah go [ __ ]
yourselves you know I just like the
drumline that's all I like other than
that you know parade music sucks
there's a couple of them bum bum ba-bum
ba-bum ba-bum ba-bum a little bit bit
bit but that's great watch everybody
prance around and their red jackets with
the gold buttons that's fine I'm all
over that but that's it once it's done
alright let's drink now let's [ __ ]
fire up the grill I don't need to see
another one of those let bad bad bad bad
but bad bad bad bad bad bad Jesus Christ
how many more coming out next ladies and
gentlemen please welcome the Girls Choir
with their little twiddle sticks
whatever the [ __ ] batons Yenta tete a
tete a tete a tete a tete a tete a tete
errata ratatatatata ter when a guru haha
you know just stand-in there my big
forehead just burning in the [ __ ] Sun
and what it what comes in the end it's
either Santa Claus or a fire engine
that's the end of the [ __ ] break all
those fireman's sitting on the truck
fresh after banging a hooker you know or
stealing the cash under somebody's
button-down in a closet when there was a
fire in the basement you know I love
talking [ __ ] about firemen not cuz I
don't respect them I just love how they
just have this [ __ ] and Dudley do-right
people love firemen they hate cops they
love firemen you know your house is on
fire they show up right you cat gets
stuck in a tree who comes running down
the street in a raincoat with a [ __ ]
ladder the goddamn firemen they get a
call you know they're not like cops
polishing off a donut they they stay
[ __ ] slide down that stripper pole and
they get out on the big red foam who the
[ __ ] doesn't like a fire engine you know
I saw a fire engine [ __ ] yesterday I
was coming out of the dog park with my
dog and there was like three of them
lined up and I guess they were doing
some CPR core I don't what the [ __ ] they
would do when they had one of the
firemen you know he was he was strapped
down to a gurney this isn't some gay
[ __ ]
they were like funny they were they were
they were learning some sort of
procedure probably how to move someone
who has got a spinal cord injury or
whatever but
all the fire engines lined up and I
gotta admit there's something there's a
little kid and everybody's you get near
a fire engines [ __ ] great big red
fire engine with all that [ __ ] chrome
you know I mean who as a kid didn't want
to be that guy at the back of the fire
engine driving the thing down the [ __ ]
Street
you know what I mean
that's what I'm gonna do someday when I
get super famous that's the perk that
I'm calling in is I'm gonna be I want to
[ __ ] drive that thing down the street
you know they take you on a straightaway
you realize how much those [ __ ]
trucks cost yeah well I don't either
I have no [ __ ] idea how much they
cost they gotta cost a lot right you
know dude you got to figure a [ __ ]
Winnebago if you get a nice one cost you
150 grand now what have you had a
Winnebago that could actually put out
fires you know or save someone with the
spinal cord injury you know I'm saying
like that that would be that'd be at
least 200 grand right you know I wonder
if I can [ __ ] Google that right now
you don't realize today if you click on
f4 you get a your computer at least on
the MacBook you get the calculator you
get the weather for the week you get a
calendar and you get a clock you know I
know that's basic computer [ __ ] that's
not my do here on the podcast you know
I'm not googling that [ __ ] I there's got
to be a fireman or two who [ __ ]
listen to this podcast right and I'm not
trashing cops by the way either I'm not
I'm just saying Oh everybody doesn't
like cops because when cops show up you
know either just got beat down by your
husband or you're getting a [ __ ]
speeding ticket you know that's when
cops show up
you know firemen show up like you know
they stick a ladder it's like very
romantic they put a ladder up to your
bedroom and they just take you away from
it all you know what maybe I'll start
that let's let's start a new segment on
this podcast where you actually you got
to tell a bad story about a group of
people that only gets good press like
either firemen what about the troops you
know straight at Reno on Memorial Day
straight across the board support the
troops you support the troops you port
the troops you know because I'm such a
[ __ ] I've actually broken down
supporting the troops you know - I
actually have so much free time that I
actually sat there and I was like really
I just have to straight across the board
support the troops every single one of
them you know every single
like there's not one [ __ ] in the Navy
that even his fellow [ __ ] people in
the Navy can't [ __ ] stand you know
there's some [ __ ] right now on a [ __ ]
aircraft carrier who's just not pulling
his weight he's always [ __ ] off and
he nobody knows exactly when to [ __ ]
pop to attention when when some when
some officer comes by you know there's
not one douchebag in the Navy that his
other Navy buddies aren't thinking to
just pushing overboard give me a [ __ ]
break
okay so IIIi support the troops but not
the douchebags how about that I'm
actually going to make that into a
bumper sticker and I'll just have a
camouflage background so no one will
question it wait wait let me let me
break it down here where you guys saying
he supports the troops we're not the
douchebags
I guess the douchebags must believe the
people who don't support the troops now
dude the douchebags are the guys who are
troops but happened to be douchebags
okay let's not speak in absolutes here
why the [ __ ] would I say [ __ ] like that
on the goddamn Memorial Day you know
what I support all the troops even a
douche bags today but on any other day I
don't fight you know I live and I live
in the real world here I'm not a live in
a real world look at me I'm [ __ ]
sitting here with an orange microphone
talking [ __ ] to [ __ ] myself I'm a
realist okay
you know me look at a look at all
what's-his-face there George Bush you
know what I mean I bet people didn't
think he was a douchebag I bet he was a
hot-shit when he was in the [ __ ]
National Guard you know taking weekends
off when he's supposed to be there he
probably took you out on his boat none I
didn't have a boat he lived in Texas
probably had a horse or some [ __ ]
isn't it amazing how that guy just he
just [ __ ] disappeared you know I
didn't agree with George Bush's policies
but there was just something about that
guy that I just really [ __ ] related
to you know what I mean like if I went
if I stopped being president the amount
of stress that has to be involved with
that [ __ ] job I gotta tell you
something dude the day that job was over
yeah that's that yeah I'd be like him
you'd never see me again or the very
least I would take like
god I'd have to take at least five
[ __ ] years off I know they told
stories about how much that job ages you
and if you don't believe it look at like
younger pictures of George Bush like how
quickly you go gray same thing happen to
uh to Bill Clinton you know or maybe
they just stopped using Grecian formula
because they got elected like well I
don't have to do this [ __ ] beauty
parlor [ __ ] anyways I got the [ __ ]
job you know I'm taking my dick out
bringing it in turn one of the easiest
impressions ever bill a little Bill
Clinton for you you like that in the end
of this I'll do a Vinny Barbarino
actually know that's one of the things
that I wish I knew how to do I wish I
knew how to do impressions I wish I wish
I could do it I can more sort of imitate
people who I hang out with but I can't
imitate famous people unless somebody
famous already does the impression then
I can do an impression of their
impression that's basically it you know
that's that's I'm sort of a hacky
impression guy and and then if you do
something really obscure which I think
I've talked to before in this podcast
like Jay Moore's Colin Quinn if you guys
seen that I'm going to put cross-promote
right now not only Jay more but the Opie
and Anthony show go on YouTube and
search jay mohr Opie and Anthony and he
calls in he does a series of
unbelievable [ __ ] impressions and the
most amazing one is he does Colin Quinn
and if you know who the [ __ ] does that
guy
like I've known Colin forever and I've
never noticed and he like ticking the
way he talks and this guy you know what
I mean
I was like one time I saw somebody do
the first person I saw do Tom Cruise the
[ __ ] show was I watching I was watching
it wasn't 30 rock excuse me how to clear
my throat wasn't 30 rock what was that
other show that that dude from friends
was on that was like 30 rock except they
were taking it seriously what the [ __ ]
was that one called like 60 degrees I
could never remember this I wasn't there
a number in it
you know to [ __ ] Jesus Christ we have to
do a sketch show as I was call Leno was
a drama but whatever but there was some
kid in there who did impressions he was
[ __ ] unreal he did a Ben Stiller and
a and a Tom Cruise that were dead on and
I I've scoured the internet trying to
find scoured is that is that really a
[ __ ] is that the right word does that
mean you got burned know scalded is
burned scoured that's not a [ __ ] word
whatever I searched high and low near
and far all over the internet I can't
[ __ ] find it but it's definitely
worth it's definitely worth checking out
and there you go I've talked myself into
a corner I don't know what the [ __ ] to
say now I just realized that usually I
just you know I get a head of steam
going this is how I do these podcasts I
could have [ __ ] a head of steam going
and I just start running until I'm out
of breath and then I go back to the
screen and and I read like questions or
whatever but you know what I'm not going
to read a question this week I'm going
to start off with uh a couple of stories
about dogs all right one funny one and
one feel-good one for the Memorial Day
holiday all right here we go
ah this comes from some [ __ ] dude I
don't name names on this alright I'm old
school
alright hey Bill I have a dog story for
you whenever I visit my parents who live
at the Jersey Shore I always take my dog
who lives with them to the beach
personally I love that sentence listen
to this whenever I visit my parents who
live in the Jersey Shore I always take
my dog who lives with them to the beach
dude if your dog lives with your parents
that's not your dog alright that's like
you know
that's like you banged it you'd [ __ ]
knocked up your 16 year old girlfriend
and you left the baby with your parents
and they raised it you know you run to
one of those douche bags in a bar it
[ __ ] 2:00 in the morning on a
Wednesday start saying oh he's got a kid
hey was he my kid I [ __ ] love whose
kid takes out a picture of it you know
that's like dude it's [ __ ] 2:00 a.m.
on a Wednesday shouldn't you be home
with your kid uh yeah I don't have a
right now she's with my parents well
then it's not your [ __ ] kid all right
you're like you're like it's brother
it's older brother who's that like like
Chuck on happy days anybody remember
that how many people out there realize
that Richie Cunningham actually had an
older brother during the first season
named Chuck and they didn't know what
the [ __ ] to do with them so they just
had him go off to college and then they
just never used him again and then after
a while they literally started just
saying that they had two kids and they
never addressed that kid anymore you
know ever again
that's what your [ __ ] dogs like sir
it's like Chuck on happy days but
anyways let's read the rest of the story
cuz this is actually a funny story my
dog is 110 pound golden retriever who
basically looks like a furry keg with
legs goddammit I can't [ __ ] read so
anyway so I had my dog at the beach and
his favorite thing to do with the beach
is to go in the water and swim after
tennis balls so one day I'm at the beach
and this is school trip of what seems to
be about fourth graders of fifth graders
and they're looking at sea life in a
jetty sir I like how you wrote jetty
like everybody knows what the [ __ ] is
Eddie is what is a jetty is that a
little pool of water that gathers during
high tide and then remains during low
tide is that what a jetty is I don't
know I know it's not a lagoon because I
watch Gilligan's Island alright so a few
of the kids came up to me and asked me
if it was okay if they could play with
my dog so I told him no problem and the
kids are getting a kick out of watch my
dog run into the water and fetch the
tennis ball so one of the kids yells
over to his friend who's busy looking in
the jetty he's like hey dude you got to
come over here and check out how cool
this dog it's at which point the kid in
the looking in the jetty says no way you
guys are missing out there's a whole
bunch of crustaceans over here so the
kid who's standing next to me
just sort of turns and looks at me and
goes what a [ __ ] and I just bursted
out laughing because I was thinking the
exact same thing
that's a [ __ ] hilarious story right
there people I don't know if it went by
you but that was a funny goddamn story
that's a funny thing about being an
adult if you're younger yeah I guess you
think that you know you're going to get
mature and you're not going to think
that [ __ ] that you would have thought in
fourth grade and that's not what being
an adult is being adult is I guess still
thinking the same [ __ ] that a fourth
grader thinks but you got to act like
you're not thinking it you know like I'd
like to think if I was there I would
have said you know you shouldn't use
that word it's very offensive
bababababa gone down that politically
correct route but I probably would have
left too you know what I mean and that
was just funny on a lot of levels where
the kid was being a little [ __ ] and the
fact that a fourth grader would say that
and the fact that it's coming out of a
fourth graders mouth you know what I
mean I I would challenge one of those
politically correct people
you know I don't you know what I just
talked myself into a [ __ ] corner
again I don't know what to say this is
one of these deals you know it is really
people I had a big argument my
girlfriend and she's walking the dog
right now I know she's coming back in a
half hour
and she's work she's gonna come in and
she's not gonna argue with me okay
follow you douche bags I think you're
gonna get a little behind the scenes
here my relationship but she's
definitely going to give me the silent
treatment and as much as I'm going to
try to block her out
it's I'm not going to be able to do it
because her silence is just going to be
[ __ ] washing over me you know so
whatever I had one of those arguments
you have you have to have in a
relationship every once in a while you
got to blow the air out of the pipes and
that's what I did and I'm going to be
paying for it today so I hope your guys
Memorial Day is working out a little
better than mine what do you think about
that okay and how about a little pat on
the back for me on a nice [ __ ]
holiday actually doing this goddamn
podcast huh seventeen [ __ ] free
minutes so far I got to tell you I'm not
doing 50 minutes I know I always say
that but I'm not doing it this week okay
I got [ __ ] to do I got laundry going all
right I got a whole bunch of [ __ ] I got
to do before I can then go to a goddamn
barbeque show off my pasty white legs
and have a burger because that's what
the [ __ ] I'm doing so anyways you know
before I get too far down the road that
is a new that is a new segment here well
you have to tell a bad story about a
group of people that just consistently
always gets good press and don't [ __ ]
make one up either okay if you have one
send one and if you don't please don't
waste my time people always try to do
that like I don't read a lot of the [ __ ]
that people send me because it's just
you know some of the revenge stories
that's why I kind of stopped doing
because they really got like ridiculous
you know they'd started getting like
James bond-esque
and I'm like dude the overhead of this
revenge is six figures okay
this didn't happen so anyways yeah if
you knew you know a nun who's being a
little Kunti one day ah who else gets
good press kids get great press you know
like they can do no wrong like they have
been unaware that they're doing wrong
you know I don't know if you don't hate
kids on some level you just not being
honest with yourself all right um what
do we got here let's go with the the
questions for the week all right
question number one bill if you had the
choice to resurrect either resurrect
either Bon Scott Jimi Hendrix or John
Bonham for one night who would you want
to see in concert
ah you son of a [ __ ] that's a hard one
huge ac/dc fan and I've always hated the
fact that I never got to see Bon Scott
but Jimmy Hendrix that would be like
being able to see [ __ ]
I can't even say Jordan because I got to
see him play I would tell you that story
when I saw uh Michael Jordan play I saw
him in North Carolina and not when he
played with the Tar Heels this is a
story for people who live in North
Carolina because I listen in the place
was not packed I might have told this
story before I can't even [ __ ]
remember I talk on my cell phone so much
my brains mush basically I was living in
North Carolina in 87-88 and it was the
year before the Charlotte Hornets were
going to start in the NBA so to get
people excited about NBA hoop you know
because obviously down there they got to
bag a road and all that [ __ ] [ __ ]
they're really big into college ball to
get people excited what they did was
they had to scrimmages at the Dean Dome
at the University in North Carolina and
what they did was they had basically two
games of professional hoop like
scrimmage hoop and each team had a
former Tar Heel on it and one of the
games was the Chicago Bulls verse I want
to say the Cleveland Cavaliers so you
had Michael Jordan former Tar Heel and
then you had Brad Daugherty on the
Cavaliers and so I've got to see Michael
Jordan back when he was skinny and he
had hair and he and he only had one dunk
but it was cool it was so early I I told
this story before I remember that I told
this story before didn't I or did I tell
it in a bar I can't [ __ ] remember but
I remember was so early in Jordan's
career I was nudging my mom going this
to watch that guy that guy's good you
know that guy's good can you [ __ ]
believe that and then the other game was
the Los Angeles Lakers because they had
James Worthy former Tar Heel and I want
to say they played the Seattle
SuperSonics and it was Sam Perkins but I
can't [ __ ] remember so if anybody
from North Carolina or if you can google
it and somehow it was in the Dean Dome I
remember that I do remember that and it
wasn't nearly it was it was probably
three-quarters full not even maybe 60%
[ __ ] full
um Jesus Christ gotta get back to the
[ __ ] questionnaire
all right bonds got Jimi Hendrix man or
John Bonham [ __ ] you know I could I
can't I can't [ __ ] answer that
john bonham moby-dick big Jimi Hendrix
wolf outside yes if I was gonna see you
know what I would have to flip a coin
which doesn't even work out
mathematically because there's three
[ __ ] people I'd have to throw a dart
all right I got a mitt Bon Scott is out
god damn it I never thought I'd say that
okay but the thing about Jimi Hendrix
and John Bonham is they date changed
Jimi Hendrix changed [ __ ] what you
thought was what you could do on the
guitar and John Bonham you know
basically he brought rock drumming into
the modern era so [ __ ] [ __ ]
what a question all right this is all I
can tell you I would throw a dart
between Jimi Hendrix and John Bonham and
when I would see Jimi Hendrix it would
be with banded gypsies not with the
experience all right because that that
live album he has we plays machine gun
and all that [ __ ] boo-boo but do you
buddy but depa do bad that one with Bob
I was at Buddy Miles on drums and uh
Billy Cox what Evers [ __ ] name is on
bass that I would I want that's what I
wanted I would want to see them on that
that wherever they take that was it in
San Francisco at the Fillmore
that [ __ ] and I would see john bonham at
Royal Albert Hall and I would be
backstage and I would be able to see his
[ __ ] bass drum foot to figure out
what the [ __ ] he was doing do you guys
ever listen to old live albums or you
ever watched old concert footage of how
polite rock shows were like the promoter
would literally come out and they would
like announce the band like on that jimi
hendrix one it's really cool like this
promoter comes out and people have this
little polite applause and they hear
this promoter going out you know welcome
to the Fillmore West tonight we have a
wonderful new band above all this type
of [ __ ] and then the background Jimi's
already playing
he says Luther thing and the [ __ ]
promoter is talking over it it gives me
chilling second he's done then they just
[ __ ] go into the song you know maybe
because I'm old now I would love to go
see a great band and be able to sit down
and just [ __ ] enjoy them as musicians
I hate the fact that I have to [ __ ]
stand up you know and look around that
douchebag who puts his [ __ ]
girlfriend on his shoulders you want to
talk about a [ __ ] pussy-whipped
individual it's already bad enough that
you probably had to buy the [ __ ]
tickets you had to pay for parking
you're already [ __ ] whatever to 300
bucks in the hole you know and then on
top of that you got to put your [ __ ]
chick on your shoulders right see you
literally your spinal cord is crunching
down so she can get up there and make
eyes over there with the [ __ ] lead
singer and possibly even flash her tits
that she'll then [ __ ] blame on
whatever the weed was [ __ ] laced with
you're actually helping her to maybe
bang another guy at that point you know
because if the lead singer likes her he
just gives the nod to the [ __ ] the
his go gather some [ __ ] guy and then
when he comes down there and he taps
your girlfriend on the shoulder says he
wants to meet him you know you're
sitting there going like you want to say
no you can't do that but you know you're
never going to hear the end of it
because that was a dream to go see
[ __ ] Eddie [ __ ] douchebag whatever
his [ __ ] name is Eddie Vetter right
I you know I totally lost control of
that story because my washing machine
just started beeping to let me know that
the load of clothes is done this is what
I'm doing with my [ __ ] my Memorial
Day I'll listen to the sirens you don't
be funny if I could actually do this
this podcast live and that was a bunch
of firemen coming over here to kick my
ass you know and just to be traditional
they didn't break down the door with an
axe they actually put the ladder up just
to confuse me Jesus Christ is my house
on fire here it comes
you ever have that moment and there it
goes
all right
he's winding down okay keep going
Jesus Christ thought my place was on
fire there for a second
um anyways so that's what I would do I
would pick between Jimi Hendrix and Bon
Scott and I would I would throw a dart
and uh I have to admit I think I would
see Jimi Hendrix and the end of it there
I made my decision I would see Jimi
Hendrix dude that was a great [ __ ]
question
that really was a great question here
comes another goddamn truck you know
what this is some douche bag on Memorial
Day already burned down their [ __ ]
backyard with their with their hibachi
Jesus Christ there's the one way you got
to steer in the back holy [ __ ] this stop
it on my street what would you do in the
middle of this [ __ ] podcast all of a
sudden somebody came on over like a
megaphone and recanted mind everybody on
the street gets to evacuate you know
that happened to me when I was a kid
Jesus Christ is four [ __ ] fire trucks
right outside my window I feel like one
of those guys I feel like Jimmy Olsen
like I'm getting the scoop right now you
know what now I have to go over and I
have to investigate let me bring my
little [ __ ] podcast station over here
you know it'd be great if there was one
right below the window and I could
actually stick my head out with I
actually wear headphones and I got this
microphone with the orange screen on it
and I just started talking like it was
the 1920s excuse me sorry what's going
on down there trying to get the scoop
why can't I open my [ __ ] windows
you know what's funny you ever notice
like whenever like some [ __ ] old lady
twists her goddamn ankle like 17 fire
trucks show up it's like is it really
necessary why don't you put all the the
old lady broke her [ __ ] hip [ __ ] on
one truck dude there's no smoke there's
nothing there's four [ __ ] two fire
trucks for fire trucks oh my god said
well that is a woman I thought that was
a guy Jesus Christ somebody just came
walking by looking like they were in one
of those you know those 80s bands that
just uh they all just had like they you
know the one-hit wonders but there was
there was there was that whole scene
like they weren't like Duran Duran they
actually thought like they were like
artistic what what the [ __ ] kind of
bands were those they weren't it wasn't
like heavy metal it wasn't rock new wave
that's right
I thought it was some guy dressed like
he was fronting a new wave band and
ended up just being I did you know you
know and girls they put their their
ponytail you know and they wrap it
around the front and he can't [ __ ]
see it dude there's no sense of urgency
now they're backing the fire truck up on
this is this is one of these times when
I just wish I was old so I could go out
there and just start yelling at him you
know about taxpayers money and [ __ ] dude
how [ __ ] up is that I was making fun
of firemen you know at the beginning of
this podcast and for [ __ ] fire trucks
show up you know what this is the thing
I have to close the window because my
voice really carries and I say [ __ ] a
lot not to mention the word [ __ ] so I'm
gonna have to you know and they always
leave the fire engines running you know
who do you think pays for that gas huh
we do see this is great this is the new
segment right here I can trash firemen
if there's a fireman listen right now is
it a fireman or a fireman you know one
of your [ __ ] is listening right
now can you answer that why when there's
no smoke there's no fire why do 18
trucks show up you guys all just bored
are you trying to get away from that get
the fat [ __ ] down the firehouse is
making the chili you know isn't it isn't
it like always there's always a cook
down there isn't there he's got one of
those big moustaches hey what are you
making today there Freddie Omega mom
making some [ __ ] chili really you're
gonna make some your famous [ __ ] red
hot chili and then I'm gonna have it had
that in my mouth and I'm gonna go fight
a [ __ ] fire you [ __ ]
how about some kool-aid
now I'm fascinated can you hear the
rumble of those engines you know a lot
of chicks like firemen they do do
something about him you know they rescue
people you know they got that raincoat
sort of perverted it's like you know
they naked under there
is he gonna [ __ ] is he gonna show me his
hose okay so there's a bunch of him
walking around they're [ __ ] raincoats
Jesus Christ you know something I gotta
admit you know what I wouldn't I would
walk out on my balcony I actually have a
little [ __ ] balcony I could be
standing on right now I could figure out
what the [ __ ] going on I can't do the
rest of this podcast this is ridiculous
was that really me talking I just went
to some accent there I usually there's
ridiculous oh this is ridiculous
all right I'm gonna try to [ __ ]
answer the rest of these questions it's
for fire trucks sit outside and people
walk around is it a chemical spill all
right that concludes part one and I have
no idea why there's such a huge echo on
this I'm using the recorder from my
[ __ ] laptop so that ends part 1 now
just go listen to part 2 just in case
you're a complete [ __ ] and you didn't
know that that's what you were supposed
to do okay
hey what's up this is bill burr and this
is part two of the Monday morning
podcast for May 25th 2009 and for the
life of me I don't know what that
[ __ ] echo was all about um oh yeah I
started to tell a story yeah when I was
a kid this [ __ ] guy's barn burned
down and evidently he ran this big
business and he had toxic toxic waste
and these big oil drums so evidently
they went around to every house in the
neighborhood knocking on the door
telling everybody to get the [ __ ] out of
their house and I don't know if they
forgot to go to our house or what but we
didn't know we didn't know so me and my
brother went out to do our paper routes
in the morning that's how white my
childhood was you know right after I had
a piece of toast with that little square
piece of butter on it I went out part of
this complete breakfast after I had my
complete breakfast I went out to do my
paper route and there was all this smoke
in the air and there was nobody we lived
on a busy street and there were no cars
and there was just this firehose going
all the way up right down the middle of
the street so we will literally like oh
wow that's cool right we didn't give a
[ __ ] so uh I ride my bike down the
street to do my first customer which is
in the direction of the fire so I drove
down there on my bicycle and there's a
fireman standing there and he's got you
know the the [ __ ] oxygen mask on and
it really looks at me and he did
literally the cartoon double-take like
yet he added it you know like what the
fleet like he couldn't believe what he
was saying it's always smoking here here
I come of my little Howdy Doody face
comes up the street riding on my little
bicycle and he comes and he starts
screaming at me through that mask going
like a couple party before just dropping
the f-bomb and I'm like I have a paper
route I had no idea thank God for what
happened at the [ __ ] so we ended up
you know maybe that's why my memory
sucks cuz i sat there breathing in
breathe in all that [ __ ]
allegedly the guy who's who whose barn
it was started RadioShack that was that
was the that was the rumor so anyways
here we go uh question number two hey
Bill I want to know what you think of
old people going going to the gym every
time I see this 60 year old guy doing
sit-ups at the gym I feel sorry for him
I workout so I can stay healthy and live
to see old age once I see old age its
mission accomplished right I think one
uh when I see these old people I think
one of two things is going on either he
doesn't know he's old which is pathetic
or he wants to grow older which is even
more pathetic
I mean how selfish can you be do you
want your family to be wiping your ass
at 90 the big question is at what age
will you stop working out I'm done at 50
I got 18 more years to go
thanks for the podcast they helped my
three hour daily commute make it much
easier well thank you sir I'm glad you
like him um don't you hate when somebody
calls you sir by the way or ma'am isn't
that the worst the first day that that
[ __ ] happens you're just like Jesus I
really am old okay when am I going to
stop working out
I got am into it I'm never gonna stop
working out but I won't be going to the
gym maybe I will be you know what I've
just I just sort of I've adjusted my
workouts too too with my age like I used
to I used to you know I used to throw
the weights around over there oh right
and you know used to play full court
hoop running up and down but my body
just can't take that I can still lift
weights and [ __ ] I just get bored doing
that but uh as I grow older I I told
myself that I'm gradually gonna morph
into yoga and Pilates
I just pause there waiting for every
Fuyu Yoga will you [ __ ] Gail
something were you stretching yourself
out you give welcome bangs in the air
you look good dude guys are so [ __ ]
dumb you know and it's just something
about anytime you do something smart
immediately it's considered feminine you
know if you do something dumb you're a
man if you don't work out and you keep
drinking red beer shoving half a [ __ ]
cow's head into your colon then then
then you're a guy but yeah that's what
I'm going to do it and no I'm not gonna
no I'm never stop going to stop working
out I'm never gonna stop trying new
things and trying to learn [ __ ] because
when you do that [ __ ] dude you die you
die and it's very easy to be 32 I've
done the math you're 32 years old it's
very easy to say that you know you're
gonna say [ __ ] it at 50 you're not dude
because at 32 if you're still working
out that means you still look good which
means women are still kind of checking
you out but I'm telling you do it starts
dropping off when it starts [ __ ]
dropping off you know you're like Jesus
Christ I don't even [ __ ] look at me
anymore
and it's it's gonna motivate you or
you'll just go into a depression and you
will spoon with that depression and
you'll eat yourself into an early grave
before you're 50 so those are your
options all right hang in that dude keep
working out you know you want to come
that do you want to come that too that
fat [ __ ] you know I'm saying we got that
big bulge of fat right above your dick
you don't be that guy you know you just
you know you get that old person I'm
gonna die soon smell it's just bad you
don't you don't to be that guy all right
you know just out of curiosity uh wonder
who the oldest person is who actually
listens to this [ __ ] podcast you know
that's another thing I always want to
stay up on music and that type of [ __ ]
I think that's easy to do when you don't
have children but uh I don't [ __ ]
know they'll just shut up and move on
with the questions all right question of
a three bill I'm from Cleveland and I've
rose really and I'm really psyched about
the Cavalier Orlando's Wednesday game it
was amazing yet a bit distressing at the
same time fortunately the Cavs lost 107
106 diptych a day the whole way through
uh do you think LeBron will lead the
Cavaliers to victory against the magic
and who do you anticipate to win the
championship
I have to admit I don't know [ __ ] about
basketball and I've started to watch
now that the Bruins and the Celtics are
knocked out you know I wasn't really
even watching the Celtics I'm just not
in the hoop and uh I gotta admit you
know Cleveland Orlando I don't think you
could ask for a better series all but
Lakers Denver that series has sucked
it's like neither team has won a game
yet
Denver blew the first game the Lakers
blew the second game and Denver blew the
third game and what's killing me is that
I don't see a dominant [ __ ] team in
the four remaining team so I think this
is kind of it's kind of a weak year I
think LeBron is the [ __ ] and I think
that [ __ ] superhero dude there what
Howard for Orlando is is ridiculous and
Kobe's ridiculous and what's-his-face
Carmelo Anthony is ridiculous and
everyone else is regular they're just
regular standing around watching those
guys doing [ __ ] you know there we go
they'll get me a lot of [ __ ] emails
all these [ __ ] hoop heads dude oh
[ __ ] can you say that stead [ __ ]
jamika whatever [ __ ] whatever some
black guy name is [ __ ] regular here
here 22 weak bones 76 I don't give a
[ __ ] Pro hoop is [ __ ] boring the
referees control the tempo of the game
and the final three minutes takes an
hour
[ __ ] that game okay what is that what is
that thing that that the commercial that
they have when's the next time great
will happen I'll tell you when the ref
stops blowing is [ __ ] whistle every
five seconds dude the second one team
goes into the penalty just kiss the rest
of your day goodbye it is the most
boring [ __ ] hundred points you're
ever going to see in your life Kobe
Bryant shoot in the front end of a one
and one he's 38 of 39 from the line
tonight 39 38 39
let's [ __ ] divide that by two
that's [ __ ] what 18:19 that would be
90 bees xx [ __ ] time he's gone to the
line 20 [ __ ] times at that point and
miss though no 18 wait can you be 38 39
yeah cuz you could you could go for a
three-point play so whatever the guy's
gonna line like [ __ ] anywhere from 16
to 20 [ __ ] times 20 [ __ ] times
they blown the whistle with one [ __ ]
guy all right I know 38 a high number
okay but there's nights where he's you
know 20 or 22 from the line one guy one
guy is stopped again 10 [ __ ] times
it's it's it's it's the worst and I got
admit I think pro football really gets
boring you know there's nothing worse
than a pro football game against two
teams that are mediocre it's just
terrible and it's one of the reasons why
I love hockey
because at the very least of two teams
suck maybe there'll be a fight you know
any other sport if there's a fight that
is the lead [ __ ] story on
SportsCenter holy [ __ ] the bench is
emptied or this guy charged the mound a
[ __ ] whatever in hockey is it
whatever that can happen in any game
it's a goddamn great sport if you like
the movie Mad Max and you don't like
hockey you're very inconsistent human
being all right let's get on with
computer tips we've been doing but very
basic computer tips helping people like
myself limp along and just to get [ __ ]
moving here I have to admit this person
brought in some computer tips this week
one two three four five of them and the
first four I knew so if you guys you
know all you guys who are really into
computer if you guys can go to the next
level here where we can talk about
preferences you know where you know they
click on the Apple and then click on
preferences go into the applications and
but if you can break down that [ __ ] that
would really help me out because I'm
really getting go to computers right now
or much better than I was because of you
guys so I appreciate it so here's the
I'll get my girlfriend's back now it's
going to get awkward's going to get
awkward alright here are some of the the
questions here question number or some
of the computer tips computer tip number
one
hold the Apple command and the letter X
to cut I mean people know the [ __ ] Apple
command in the letter C to copy Apple
command and the letter V to paste and
this is the one I didn't know Apple
command and the letter Z to undo I
didn't know that one and that one
basically this guy so eloquently puts
when you just [ __ ] up any document
email or typing that you just did if you
delete something by accident and then
hit the just hit Apple Z and you get it
back and he goes god I know you have to
know the f3 button to separate the
screens by now but I just want to make
sure since that [ __ ] is on the Mac you
know what dude I didn't know that one
f3 you hit that and that separates all
your windows within which point I said
what is f4 do and that's when I found
the calculator the date my forecast for
the week and the time so that's pretty
[ __ ] cool I'll actually have to start
the podcast with that so I won't know
the dates but and before anyone can you
know I'm kind of being an arrogant ass
here because I am a [ __ ] so if you
don't know [ __ ] like that that Apple
command and the letter X is basically
when you just highlight whatever you
just did if you hit the command button
in letter X that will just delete the
sentence you know
Apple see that we'll copy it and then
Apple vu paste it to somewhere else it's
very easy to figure out but I think at
this point everybody's caught up so if
you guys do computer tips if you want to
take them to the next level that would
be greatly appreciated and all you
[ __ ] douchebags out there who are
good at computer just feel really good
and so [ __ ] basic this [ __ ] that you
suck at alright okay look at me getting
all defensive alright you want to hear a
heartwarming dog story and I'll end the
podcast here and actually I want I'm
going to blow through some underrated
overrated because a lot of people sent
some [ __ ] in okay heartwarming dog story
uh oh and also I got to have douche bag
of the week I forgot about that one
heartwarming dog story uh alright bill
you've probably got a lot of emails were
gonna doug i have a dog that we found
five years ago i was driving home after
work and i saw a yellow lab mix in the
middle of the road she was running
across a busy street with an e collar on
one of those things the vets put on a
dog and uh i don't know the [ __ ] dog
is better this is a really long story so
she's running across the street and
nobody was stopping she was really
scared and confused running all over the
street everyone was honking their horns
and she was just running back and forth
not sure where to go basically she was
freaking out so i saw in the middle in
the mid section of the street waiting to
turn when i saw i called for her to come
over which she did and i opened my car
door and yanked her in the car dude you
got more balls than me i would
definitely feel bad for the dog but I
saw Old Yeller at the wrong age and I've
never just like jaws I saw jaws when I
was young and I will not go into the
ocean and if there's a [ __ ] stray dog
freaking out I'm not going to yank it in
my car for fear of getting rabies I
quickly noticed she had a surgical scar
on her stomach
this dog was scared and she had the most
desperate look in her eyes it really
shook me so I brought her home and I put
her in the yard while I got our dogs put
in place where they wouldn't see each
other since I didn't know how this dog
would behave see this guy really knows
about dogs here I quickly found that she
was terrified and would not leave my
sight she would come over to me and sit
on my feet and follow me everywhere I
went
so we put her in a different room away
from our other dog my wife and I got a
plan together to find her owner she was
so sweet and terrified she must need to
get back to her house with her owners
right so we put up signs and went around
to neighbor's house house the house
door-to-door to see if we could find the
owner no luck the next day my wife went
to the nearest vet office because we
figured that's where she had a surgery
done well they had never seen her before
but said the vet the vet said he wanted
to scan her for a microchip turns out
she had one and she was from a no-kill
shelter so we called the shelter she was
from turns out they kept her at a
veterinarians house down the street
bababababa and they said that they would
come over and pick her up but by this
time I was having second thoughts after
only two days or other dog had taken to
her as well as well this dog loved me
after only two days and I can't explain
it because my other dog could care less
about me it's my wife's dog and I and
don't get me wrong I love him but this
was different this dog somehow got into
my heart see this is what happened with
Cleo I got the dog and after two days I
[ __ ] love the dog so anyways the vet
told us her story which was verified
later on by the shelter rep who came to
approve us to adopt her for a home turns
out she was given up I'm really [ __ ]
flaking here turns up she was given up
by everyone in the families that adopted
her she was adopted five times dude
that's not a red light flashing she was
adopted five times and they keep getting
rid of her anyways over the years she's
developed some minor behavioral issues
such as digging and getting out of the
yard she was placed in when left alone
but whatever her name is Bella and while
she was a pain in the ass at the time
she is as you said what I come home to
and basically do it actually loves a dog
arrest of the dog and says congrats on
Cleo well thank you I appreciate that
you know I don't know there was
something really cool I guess about
rescuing a dog but there are a lot of if
you're a realist there's a lot of red
flags there dog have been adopted five
[ __ ] times
ah you know I don't know it's a great
thing god bless you if you adopt a dog
alright let's get on to douche bag of
the week alright his douche bag of the
week some reason this person sends me
this email right in the middle of my day
hey Bill nice move assuming I'm a female
I guess I read one of this this person's
questions and I assumed that they were a
female so they got all upset going nice
move assuming I'm a female since I never
signed my name and when you read my
comments on your podcast and always
refer to me as a male it's just
interesting how people will determine if
a person is male or female
without ever meeting them and just
reading what they write why can't a
woman write something about baseball or
hockey say saying something true saying
some true overrated [ __ ] without being
assumed a male and this is after she the
first email email she wrote she wrote
bill [ __ ] you and then I wrote hey
sweetie
happy Monday to you okay
so then she sends me this other email
you know it's just really interesting
how when people send emails without ever
meeting and they assume with their male
or female so I just wrote back really
you know that's it that's all that
deserved really you know what I mean
first of all sweetheart I don't know if
you realize it but in the subject area
up top it has your full name which is a
female name and I don't know if you
realize this but I get a ton of [ __ ]
emails and I don't say people's names so
I delete the names and I just read them
okay and at that point I don't know
whether it's male or female it's not a
[ __ ] sexist thing you [ __ ]
psychopath I keep referring to my dog as
a male because I [ __ ] always had male
dogs my girlfriend keeps giving me [ __ ]
I go I gotta take him out she's like her
you know but it's not like you know I
wouldn't hire you if you had the right
what if
can you're a douchebag all right you're
a big [ __ ] douche but you know you're
such a big douchebag that literally
twelve other douche bags could climb in
your douche bag that's how big a [ __ ]
douche bag you are okay
I'm not assuming anything I get a ton of
[ __ ] emails and if somebody writes
about hockey yeah I do assume that
they're [ __ ] mail the same way if
somebody wrote about crocheting a
[ __ ] Afghan I would assume that
they're a female I wouldn't be trying to
insult the rosey Grier [ __ ] guy who's
in done it again that's a female thing
to do all right doesn't mean I don't
respect you and your vagina and your
knowledge about hockey you know you know
what from now on I'm just gonna I'm
gonna [ __ ] I'm gonna say the gender
of everybody all right like here's an
email from someone who has a dick just
two quick notes in regards to the
caveman killer remember last week the
serial killer thing using a sharpened
stick as a weapon and then burning it is
so there would be no evidence there's a
bit of a problem here
although it's genius and inventive an
inventive way to do it he would get
caught when the autopsy was performed
they would come across the fibers dirt
and residue left behind by said stick
they would then do an analysis on the
residue to find out what what it was
composed of and what type of tree was
used to make Swiss cheese of the victim
now having that information the
authorities would then plot out a map of
every single area within the state or
vicinity of the victim to narrow down
where the stick could have come from
they would then Jesus crisis is long
they would then narrow down that further
based on the composition of the dirt and
any traces of nutrients and figure out
exactly where the stick what area the
stick came from a mass search would then
take place in said area and more likely
they would be able to pinpoint the spot
where the earth was disturbed or the
branch that was broken within a 24 to 48
hour window concluding that this is the
spot where the weapon was obtained they
would then probably find fibers from the
clothing of the perpetrator so they
would match that later after
pointing out a new story with the
evidence they had someone come forward
saying they saw a car a person in the
area that seemed to be out of place
sketch sketch drawing would be done and
released the can the caveman killer
would be located and arrested putting a
nice tight bow on the case
would be their ability to match the dirt
from the spot where the weapon was found
in the the dirt found on the bottom of
the shoes that were in the garage of
said caveman killer further
investigation in the vehicle would find
more traces of that dirt on the floor
mats from the shoes and on the seat
where the weapon was placed on the way
to the OP the offing sorry to say mr.
cave sorry to say mr. caveman game over
have fun playing hide the stick in
prison over the next 50 years to life
Jesus Christ you got to give it up to
that guy for breaking it down I know
he's kind of he was only semi serious
there he's talking about like those
[ __ ] a any murder things because
that's literally how people get caught
likes I saw one with this guy suffocated
somebody with a with a trash bag and
somehow they figured out that that's how
they did it and they were able to find
the impression of the woman's face in
the bag it was one of the creepiest
things ever and but I got to tell you
something you know I know you just half
joking around but most of that shit's
just circumstantial evidence and if you
don't have the weapon all you have is
all the guys to say what I like to go
hiking in that area yes I hiked in that
area yes my fibers were that you you
know it's still all circumstantial at
that point if you have no priors or
anything like that that's a whole bunch
of circumstantial evidence and I don't
you know if you get a good lawyer you're
going to get off you're going to get off
um and I think that's it for the monday
morning podcast this week look at up to
54 minutes it happened again and I did
you know why because the goddamn fire
trucks and I didn't even get a chance to
get to the underrated overrated yet but
you know these things are really
building up so I got to blow through
these okay overrated driving fast not
many things make me angrier on the road
than when I'm driving 75 miles per
our and I'm getting tailgated really is
75 not [ __ ] fast and a few people you
know something I you know that really
annoys the [ __ ] out of me too sometimes
I'll bump it up to 80 and people are
still riding my ass what the [ __ ] I can
understand and appreciate the need to
get somewhere quickly but is that that
doesn't mean that wherever you need to
go is more important than my need to
arrive at my destination in one [ __ ]
piece well that is true but you know
something I got to argue for the other
guy here that if somebody is riding your
ass you really should get out of the way
you know but I know that's that whole
guy thing then you feel like a [ __ ] you
know so what do you got to do you got to
stomp on the brakes and be a [ __ ]
[ __ ] but really I got a myth though
if you are doing 75 80 in the left lane
somebody's still riding your ass I don't
know when you get a little older and
more relaxed you don't give a [ __ ] you
do you do go over to the right like I do
now and say one out of 40 times you do
that you actually get to see the guy get
a speeding ticket a little further down
the road but the other thirty ten nine
times the other 39 times you feel like a
[ __ ] I got a mint underrated quiet time
remember we used to have quiet time in
grade school I wish that was still
around I work at a TV station and I like
the guys I work with but sometimes I
just need everyone to shut the [ __ ] up
do we have to be running our mouths
every goddamn second for the next eight
hours just sit there and do your work
for a bit
we'll talk later Jesus you know what
dude I totally [ __ ] relate to exactly
some people just don't like [ __ ]
silence you know they find it awkward
and they got to keep running the mouth
kind of like me for the last [ __ ]
hour Jesus Christ alright underrated TV
show The Deadliest Warrior on Spike TV
just look the [ __ ] up it pits two
different Warriors together from
different time eras and they see who
would win dude
that really sounds like some nerdy
[ __ ] [ __ ] isn't that like who do you
think would win an alligator or a shark
I don't know who either would win
Chewbacca or Spock I don't get into that
[ __ ] but you know what god bless you sir
those people out there went to it so I
guess you know go check it out uh real
quick
over
rated woman's intuition I've always
heard educated intelligent women say
that women's intuition is always correct
sorry you're wrong if that were true why
do women repeatedly date abusive twisted
guys wouldn't their intuition tell them
that the guy what the guy is like yet
another reason of women patting
themselves on the back for no reason all
right sir you know what [ __ ] that chick
okay
whoever dumped you just [ __ ] her man you
know there's gonna be another good girl
coming around don't give in to the
bitterness don't give in to the
bitterness or maybe that's just from
dating for a while because there's a lot
of the major part of me really like that
email yet another example of women
patting themselves on the back for no
reason Jesus Christ if that sentence
doesn't describe the Oprah Winfrey Show
I don't know what does um great great
one all right here we go uh in women if
you're sitting there getting mad you can
because you can always [ __ ] trash guys
because I'll read them I'll definitely
read them and I know we deserve it all
right number two Disney movies
okay I'm 35 years old now but even as a
kid I thought those sugary [ __ ] movie
sucked bloody balls all right dude
[ __ ] way to let me know how you feel
overrated interlocking lives
interlocking lives movies like crash and
Fast Food Nation get it we're all
connected this [ __ ] is getting old that
movie crash was so [ __ ] overrated so
[ __ ] that's one of those movies just
because it was about race people thought
that it was saying something question
number four the movie stir crazy I love
Richard Pryor he was one of the best
ever but this movie is average his
talent is pretty much wasted on this
film yeah I would have to say that is
that the one where they walk into the
into the jail you know that's right
uh-huh we bad we bad that's like the
funniest part of the movie I don't know
I would have to agree with you that's it
though guys I'm actually coming up on a
[ __ ] hour here 59 minutes 25 seconds
listen that's the podcast you guys all
have a
Memorial Day and I really should have
made this one short so you could
actually enjoy your Memorial Day but you
know what you got the whole week to
listen to it and if you listen to this
on Tuesday that means you're back at
that [ __ ] job you hate and I just
killed an hour for you so god bless all
right have a great week